let's see where would you rank it on
your favorite Marvel movies um honestly
hmm I would say X I'm sorry Iron Man 1
is at the top number two would be
Captain America and number three would
be Captain America the Winter Soldier
number four would be 4 and the number 5
would be this movie I thought it was
actually it was really good I really
enjoyed it not think it'd be it was it
was a really good film it was it was it
was pretty sweet let's see his Bishop
the main character or is Logan its
Wolverines the main character Bishop in
a supporting character he really doesn't
have a major role in the film the only
time you see him as a course in the
future it's the story really revolves
around Wolverine beast and Magneto and
mystique and Charles Xavier that's
really kind of where the story lies I'm
Wolverine of course though is is the
main character just wondering what you
thought about the age difference between
the Maximoff siblings assuming the
little girl was Wanda when they're
supposed to be twins and the comics and
the age gap between Pho and Eric didn't
seem quite right yeah the age gap
between Quicksilver and Magneto just
didn't quite seem the way we suppose
people you're talking about it there's a
huge gap that I mean we're I mean you
know magneto was I would go as far as to
say maybe 12 13 years old and the
beginning of x-men last stand and that
was during World War two
this is 1973 so we're talking about you
know let's let's say that maybe this
took place in 1943 he's at least thirty
years old you know he might even be well
into his forties so I would say that
that gap kind of seems about right now
that I think about it I mean seems about
right in terms of the actual age now in
terms of Quicksilver and the Scarlet
Witch as I understand it that's not the
Scarlet Witch that supposed to just be a
younger sister of his she's not actually
build out of the Scarlet Witch and the
Scarlet Witch to my knowledge doesn't
actually appear in x-men Days of Future
past I could be wrong here but I don't
believe I am let's see do they ever
explain how Professor X comes back to
life I know he was at the end of the
Wolverine but I must have missed if they
explained was that cable as a little boy
kid has an M on his face when the
mutants were being
we need more rounded up or are all
mutants in the future marked with that
what are your reactions on the new and
vastly improved sentinels thanks in
advance you're welcome in advance all
right so let's let's take this first one
do they explain how professor actually
comes back to life no he's just there we
assume that of course because the the
movie retcons because it pretty much
says that x-men last and never happened
he never actually died and so because he
didn't die of course he's he's there now
in terms of was that cable as a little
kid no cable comes from a future that's
fifteen centuries beyond the Days of
Future Passed timeline cable comes from
a thirty ninth century which is the year
you know four thousand or something like
that I can't member he's a couple
thousand years ahead he's born here he's
he's raised I'm sorry he's born in the
present but he's raised a couple
thousand years into the future
after the Days of Future past you know
that to my knowledge that it's not cable
that's something just a kid with an M on
his face okay what are your reactions on
the new and vastly improved sentinels
okay so this was an interesting thing to
me this was really kind of kind of
interesting actually thought it was cool
and I know there's gonna be some people
who are you know traditionalists in
terms of the sentinels but actually
thought it was cool and the reason why
is because you've got some care there
were some crazy powers and the way that
it's done you know they have full use of
their abilities the mutants do and the
comics they had inhibitor collars and
that's really what they were wearing if
when you saw the opening credits and you
saw those things on the back of their
necks with the the orange circle or kind
of oval that was an inhibitor collar and
it kept the mutants from being able to
use their powers in this one they don't
have inhibitor collars so they have full
use of their abilities I think was a
great idea to really make the Sentinels
more formidable in a sense that they
would adapt to everything because it
really kind of establishes the fact that
there really is no overcoming this
future there's no getting past it that
in the end all these mutants are really
doing is just kind of delaying the
inevitable
you know they're all going to die unless
they change the future change the past
and I think that the the Sentinels
really kind of being as powerful as they
were is
stand-in for the comics when they had
nuclear nuclear threat because in the
comics the whole reason why it was
important that they destroy the Sentinel
program was because the signals were
going to move outside of North America
and the rest of the world had said that
if the signals expanded outside of North
America that they were going to launch a
nuclear strike against the United States
and so in the comics you had this effort
to destroy the Sentinel program in the
future at the same time that Kitty Pryde
is trying to help the x-men stop the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelly
Charlie Xavier and more metallic in the
past and so instead of having a threat
of nuclear nuclear war and this movie
they instead kind of replaced that with
sentinels that were just basically
unstoppable so in the end there was
going to be total destruction but at
this point you know it was just really
kind of gonna be at the hands of signals
as opposed to two nuclear bombs let's
scroll down a little bit further what do
you think is better Captain America 2 or
x-men Days of Future past
Captain America 2 you definitely tell me
how you feel about Robert DaCosta
sunspot powers and his role in the film
ok so I I don't remember whether we
answered this or not I may have
forgotten but ok so sunspot I think is I
think we did answer this she's really
kind of an amalgamation of Sunfire and
sunspot in the sense that Sunfire can
absorb solar energy and project plasma
or fire and sunspot I'm sorry yeah Sun
Fire absorbs plasma energy Akers absorbs
solar energy and projects fire with it
or plasma and sunspot absorbs solar
energy and uses it for physical strength
we saw him shooting fire out of his
hands and so it was really I think kind
of a nod to Sun fire but then we also
saw him I think use physical strength
which is of course as the base power the
inherent ability of sunspot himself
spoiler who do you think the four
horsemen will be ok so like we said I
don't think the four horsemen in terms
of the reveal and the post-credits
trailer really matters it just
establishes to us the fact that
apocalypse has four horsemen so we know
that he is already very powerful in
addition to the fact that he's creating
the pyramids in front of us using his
mind which is crazy powerful but I think
that if they decide to go ahead and go
with the day the Age of Apocalypse
storyline
I don't know I mean you know you might
have someone like Inc you know who might
play the role of pestilence you might
have somebody like Wolverine who will
play the role of death they might bring
an archangel and have them play the role
of death I have no idea who they're
gonna be you know the problem here is
that death is the most commonly
interchanged character when it comes to
apocalypses horsemen you had Wolverine
as death you had gambit I think it's
death although he might have been war
you had Archangel is death you know
death is the one that interchanges the
most so the other three you know
pestilence famine and I cannot remember
the last war those are the ones that
really kind of stay the same for the
most part they don't they don't really
change so you know at this point I don't
want to speculate because I'm I have no
earthly clue we haven't been given that
many characters so far I mean we've only
really been given a handful of
characters to work with and so there's
never been an instance where really
anything more than two of these
characters have ever been one of
apocalypse as horsemen so I have no
earthly clue who the who the horsemen
are going to be do you like The Sentinel
design okay we answer that part about
the civil design our Magneto's powers
constrained or restrained by plot budget
or vision not really there's actually a
point where he lifts the entire stadium
like lifts an entire football field into
the air and then drops it over the White
House there's this great big huge
barrier around the White House which is
really cool
do you like the time travel aspect of
the movies or time travel in general as
a plot device not really because I feel
like it's it's a magic eraser they say
okay well you know we kind of wrote
ourselves into a whole time travel let's
fix the problem I don't really like that
I really liked you know I think that if
time travel is taken away from the
equation that it really kind of requires
the writer to make a more dynamic story
because now not only do they have to
create a compelling story they have to
create a compelling ending to this story
as opposed to just kind of using a magic
eraser and saying okay you know somebody
travel back in time they change the past
and now everything is fixed this is
really kind of an easy out and I don't
really care for that too much
let's see who is your favorite marvel
I'm sorry movie x-men character man I
would say the younger Magneto you know I
really think that that he is I mean he's
a great character
you know Michael Fassbender plays him
really really well and he's really
dynamic and he's really complicated and
he's really intriguing I would say that
Michael Fassbender is Magneto
it's probably my favorite favorite
character from the x-men movies who is
your favorite x-men character okay just
in general I guess probably mad Jim
Jasper's is one of my favorite
characters because he's just so cool and
kooky and he's super powerful he's a
either he has the ability to warp
reality there were some people that can
do that stuff too like mr. M I think in
work reality and stuff but but yeah mad
Jim Jasper's is probably my favorite
character let's see
what's your I'm sorry I liked the 90s
cartoon do you think you will enjoy the
movie or it doesn't matter I think
you'll enjoy the movie you know it's
it's there are some similarities between
the 90s cartoon and and the the movie
but you know the movie really kind of
stands on its own two feet you could
have never seen X been the animated
series go in and watch the movie and
walk away understanding what's going on
so the movies not really like a the the
TV shows not really a prerequisite for
understanding the movie